[Musique]
dès aujourd'hui plus simplement un jouet
pour grandes personnes
syfy fureur dans les années 30 ce
revenant c'est le yoyo leiris ailleurs
champion du monde de yoyo et américains
évidemment est venu tout exprès en
europe pour nous reconvertir aux joies
scène de ce jeu sans prétention un jeu
qui l'a élevé cependant à la hauteur
d'une science les premiers froids vont
chasser les squares et des jardins
publics de france et de navarre ces
groupes attentif sérieux réfléchi
l'hiver est là ce n'est pas une saison
pour jouer aux billes du moins pour les
joueurs sérieux
il convient de préciser que dûment
codifié enregistré réglementairement au
journal officiel le jeu de billes n'est
plus aujourd'hui en france abandonné à
la fantaisie de godelureaux en culottes
courtes
l'initiative vient de marseille où il
garde un petit air de pétanque
[Musique]
madame savez comme ils s'appellent
instruments là un mauvais pas
[Musique]
au début j'ai laissé tomber un moment
parce que je n'arrivais pas puis après
j'ai repris je sais qu une méthode et à
partir de là ça produit aller au bout
d'un an
est-ce que c'est toujours le stade
rochelais annoncé laisserait aux chiens
dans les échos pour aller plus vite sur
une quelque chose qu'on trouve assez
souvent position dans ton souvent
qu'après ça les pupitres de trivision le
pays possible sur mal combien maintenant
record en prime voici le nouveau jeu qui
va faire fureur dans les cours de
récréation
on les croyait t'oublier c'était
seulement un manque de savoir faire
les hausses les lardons le fruit de la
plus haute technologie et de la
curiosité
la fabricant nous avons pris ce qui
était sûr marché nous avons trouvé deux
types d'osselets et nous les avons
testés avec les enfants
alors qu'il y avait un type de cela
c'est lourd métallique qui est assez
difficile parce qu'il fait mal lorsqu'on
enclos serait assez haut et il y avait
un autre type dos mais alors en
plastique simple très très léger et avec
lequel jouait devient très difficile
parce qu'il survole trop facilement
[Musique]